welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this
morning we got our first full look at
the upcoming what-if series from Marvel
Studios the images follow up on last
month's view frame reveals at Disney D
23 which showed Peggy Carr are being put
through the machine that created Captain
America and injected him with Super
Soldier Serum and then we saw her in
full uniform holding up the shield as
Captain Britain
I think should it be Captain Peggy
Carter anyway this was followed up this
morning by more images that were posted
on Twitter and there's quite a lot to
unpack from them firstly it seems like a
lot of these are very heavily Peggy
Carter focused and I think it's a safe
bet to assume that this will be the
first show that the project will be
leading with as in chronological order
it's also one of the main starting
points of the MCU
though there are rumors that the
Eternals will change this up heavily and
actually put the origin back 35,000
years to when the Celestials roam the
galaxy in the images we can see what
looks to be Steve Rogers still
incredibly skinny and I think it's safe
to assume that he will still feature in
the Peggy Carter episode even if he's
just glanced over and cast aside so that
Peggy can be the chosen one for the
super-soldier program he also appears to
be in a tank at one point potentially as
part of the Howling Commandos fighting
alongside captain Carter and taking down
what I imagine will be the Red Skull we
can also see Peggy at one point riding
on top of what looks to be an Iron Man
esque machine so this may even confirm
the theory that similar to Steve Peggy
is frozen in ice at the end of the
episode and she could wake up in the
present and join The Avengers perhaps
even going on to become their leader
similar to steve sebastian stan has to
being cast in the episode so I think
it's a safe bet that the picture of
Bucky that we see will also feature at
the end perhaps setting up the events of
an alternative Winter Soldier what if
series down the line
however Bucky and Peggy didn't really
have the relationship that he and Steve
did so I can imagine that if they do go
that route the events of the film will
play out
be different star low two can be seen
here and this backs up the rumors that
the what-if series we'll explore the
alternate timeline with the character
that was created in Avengers end game
where star-lord was knocked out the
Power Stone was taken and Thanos nebula
and the Black Order were killed it could
potentially show Ronan the accuser as
the person who gets the Infinity stones
and that definitely would be an
interesting direction to take and lastly
perhaps the most interesting one is the
image of Steve as a zombie the where
room is that Marvel Zombies was going to
be making an appearance as a what-if
special and this pretty much confirms it
the Marvel Zombies series is a blast and
it's such a black comedy that this will
definitely be awesome to see as its own
episode a thing that this will probably
be one of the most fun episodes as all
of the graphic novels that center around
the zombies have a real dark humor to
them as we watch the heroes go through
the galaxy eating it planet by planet
there's so much to impact from this and
I have seen some people say that they
don't really like the animation style
but I think it looks really good it
reminds me a lot of the anime tricks and
love death and robots and I think that
the fact that Marvel had brought
together the full cast of the film's
that each spin-off is based on will lead
to the show's being very high quality
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on these images and which episode out of
them that you're looking forward to the
most comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
check out my breakdown of the top 10
most powerful quotes from the MCU I go
over the lines that impacted me the most
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to trip down memory lane if you
want to come talk to me about movies TV
shows games and comic books and you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
you
[Music]